ja über diese aktuelle netflix serie
sprechen wir etwas später zuerst dabei
lernen sie die frau kennen deren leben
die dreh vorlage geliefert hatte brach
feldmann
sie brach mit ihrer vergangenheit im
ultra-orthodoxen jüdischen milieu in
brooklyn new york und schrieb dann zwei
welt- bestseller darüber wir sprechen
heute über die herkunft die sie hinter
sich gelassen hat und was es bedeutet
mit der eigenen vergangenheit zu brechen
herzlich willkommen der befällt wenn ich
freue mich sehr dass sie uns aus berlin
zugeschaltet sind
ich freue mich auch sehr dass ich
zugeschaltet sein kann und darf ja frau
feldmann sie schreiben die frage aller
fragen sei für sie wie sie ihr
jüdischsein für sich erträglich machen
können haben sie darauf eine antwort
gefunden
ich glaube schon dass sich heute darauf
eine antwort gefunden habe aber es geht
es geht natürlich um diese
erträglichkeit weil ich in einer welt
aufgewachsen bin wo mir das bild also
den bezug zum judentum natürlich sehr
erschwert wurde
ich bin in eine gemeinde groß geworden
die mir einen zugang zu gott quasi
verwehrt hat oder zumindest in diesen
zugang vermitteln wollte und bestimmen
wollte und da neue bezüge und und
anknüpfen zu finden ist danach sehr
schwierig ja da braucht man eine lange
zeit sie in ihrem ersten buch das ja
eben sehr schnell und unerwartet für den
verlag ein riesenhit wurde merkt man
sehr schnell dass sie als kind
eigentlich so gar nicht in diese
gemeinschaft passen weil die so
reglementiert ist auch sie hinterfragen
immer wieder das verhalten ihres
umfeldes sie gehen in die bibliothek
leihen sich verbotene bücher aus sie
beklagen sich irgendwie auch über die
kleidung dieses ob irgend wie schwer und
einengend ist wann wussten sie denn dass
diese welt in der sie leben nicht ihre
welt ist ja wahrscheinlich schon sehr
früh weil man mir das auch klar gemacht
hat die gemeinde hat mit alles klar
gemacht weil
ich ja ein produkt eine gebrochene ehe
war und gebrochenen gibt es in dieser
gemeinde sehr selten die bedeuten große
skandale und grund dafür
für scham und ekel und horror und ich
war die erinnerung an diese ehe meiner
eltern die sehr schnell gescheitert ist
und ich war also schon von anfang an das
problem und mir hat man das vermittelten
das bedeutet ich habe mich schon anders
gefühlt als kind ich habe schon als kind
gespürt ich gehöre irgendwie nicht dazu
egal wie sehr ich das möchte
oder möchten sollte man wird mir diese
zugehörigkeit eigentlich nie geben es
gibt keine möglichkeit die zu verdienen
ob ich war bereit alles zu tun die zu
verdienen
aber als kind war ich schon an der marge
diese gemeinde und habe deshalb mit
einer perspektive eine außenseiterin
schon auf diese gemeinde geblickt also
ich war gezwungen wie eine außenseiterin
darauf zu schauen
also man muss dazu vielleicht noch sagen
eben ihre mutter ist ja auch schon aus
der gemeinde dann ausgetreten sie hat
sich für eine frau entschieden lebt mit
einer frau zusammen also von daher sind
sie quasi schon stigmatisiert worden
jetzt sprechen sie von der außensicht
wie war denn die innensicht ich habe das
zuvor auch so ein bisschen geschrieben
dass sie immer wieder mit dieser
gemeinschaft gehadert haben weil was sie
jetzt beschrieben haben ist finding was
man von außen auf sie quasi gedrückt hat
wie sie eben nicht reinpassen ja genau
und es gab aber gleichzeitig diesen
großen wunsch irgendwie einen weg zu
finden in diese gemeinde doch rein zu
passen zugehörigkeit und akzeptanz zu
finden eben mein glück in dieser welt
doch zu erkoren und dadurch haben sich
zwei verschiedene selbst entwickelt es
gab ein selbst das brava und und und
folgsam und wollte zeigen dass sie alles
richtig machen alles wie die anderen
macht aber es gab zugleich ein privates
inneres selbst das dann zweifel hatte
dass alles hinterfragt hatte dass mit
dieser außenseiterinnen
sich geschaut hat und diese zwei selbst
haben sich über den jahren voneinander
langsam entfernt es gab einen wachsenden
distanz zwischen diesen zwei selbst und
irgendwann war die spannung so intensiv
weil die distanz so groß geworden ist
dass ein bruch einfach unvermeidbar war
und das finde ich sehr spannend ich frag
mich nur wenn menschen zwei solche ich
wie sie es beschreiben aufbauen wie
entscheidet sich dann welches ich über
das andere quasi siegt weil sie sagen es
gab diesen bruch ja es ist interessant
darüber habe ich lange nachgedacht ich
habe versucht auch deshalb in mein leben
zu schreiben um gerade diesen prozess zu
verstehen weil in meinem ersten buch
geht es ja eigentlich darum zu verstehen
wie es zu dieser entscheidung kommen
kann zu gehen was was man alles braucht
um diese entscheidung treffen zu können
und ich denke irgendwann wird es sehr
klar dass ein selbst falsch ist das ein
selbst sogar destruktiv ist dass man
droht in diesem falschen selbst
unterzugehen sich aufzulösen sich zu
verlieren
man merkt irgendwann dass es eine
richtige bedrohung wert diese spannung
zwischen den selbst und man muss eine
seite wählen muss eine loyalität zu
einem selbst entwickeln und die
loyalität geht dann automatisch zu
diesem selbst dass sich echt und
authentisch anfühlt das nicht unter
druck ist irgendwas vorzugeben oder zu
spielen
sie haben dann ja mit 17 auch sie wurden
verheiratet sie kannten diesen man
eigentlich nicht war das für sie ein
glücklicher moment oder nicht auf jeden
fall war das ein glücklicher moment
ich habe mich gefreut
den mann kennenzulernen den ich heiraten
würde ich habe mich gefreut mit ihm
verlobt zu werden
ich habe mich auf die hochzeit gefreut
ich war natürlich ein bisschen nervös
kurz vor der hochzeit als man mir dann
plötzlich alles beigebracht hat als ich
dann zum ersten und letzten mal meinem
leben
verhütung so die verhütungspille hätte
nehmen muss weil man wollte ja sicher
gehen dass sich an der nacht der
hochzeit nicht blut und deshalb dürftig
nur in diesen vier wochen die pille
nehmen also in diesem monat vor der vor
der hochzeit war ich schon ein bisschen
nervös weil ich sehr viel neue
informationen erfahren habe für die ich
gar nicht vorbereitet war und von der
ich mich gar nicht vorstellen könnte
diese information in meinem leben
umzusetzen aber ich habe trotzdem sehr
viel freude und hoffnung gehabt weil ich
dachte hier ist endlich meine chance
dann werde ich endlich in diese gemeinde
reinpassen würde mich akzeptieren ich
würde ihren respekt haben
ich werde endlich angekommen sein im
leben und ich werde vielleicht sogar ein
bisschen freiheit haben und vielleicht
sogar ein bisschen von dieser autorität
die ich bei den anderen frauen in meiner
gemeinde beobachtet habe und dann aber
in dieser ganzen hoffnung und freude
irgendwie sie haben es zuvor angedeutet
es gibt diese ehe vorbereitungskurse
lernen sie plötzlich es entstehen
probleme weil man erwartet dass sie
schwanger werden
man erwarte sie schwanger werden in
einem konzept wo sie bisher sexualität
überhaupt nicht gekannt haben
das sieht man sehr schön im film auch
female pressure wo wir an ein spieler
haben ja im einspieler sieht man eben
diesen aufklärungsunterricht der vorder
hochzeit stattgefunden hat wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe da haben sie
auch das erste mal vermittelt bekommen
dass sie an die vagina haben richtig
also ich wusste natürlich dass der
weibliche körper als bedrohungen diese
gemeinde galt ich wusste dass der
weibliche körper als grund für für alle
art schlechte geschehnisse in der welt
gesehen wurde und das
der zu jeder zeit zu verstecken und
bedecken war und zu verleugnen und ich
habe keine beziehung zu meinem eigenen
körper gehabt und als ich mit 13 zum
ersten mal meine tage bekommen habe war
ich sehr sehr erschrocken und mir würde
einfach gesagt das ist ganz normal so
reinigt sich sein körper das haben alle
und ich habe gedacht männer haben das
auch also ich hab das einfach nicht
hinterfragt und es ist mir nicht in den
kopf gekommen dass ich irgendwas
sozusagen an meinem körper vielleicht
hätte der zu dem zweck der fortpflanzung
dienen sollte ich hab' ich habe das
einfach nicht durch gedacht als kind ich
habe verstanden kinder kommen in die
welt ich wusste das muss irgendwie
hinhauen aber also mir sind alle anderen
möglichkeiten angefallen wie das sein
kann aber die echte sozusagen die der
echte prozess ist mir einfach nicht in
den kopf gekommen dann hat mir das einen
monat oder sogar an einigen wochen vor
der hochzeit erklärt und zwar mit diesen
metaphern so es würde auch so vage
vermittelt so so wirklich schwierig zu
entziffern und gerade weil es so
schwierig ist zu entziffern was sie
damit meinen hat man ja auch angst
fragen zu stellen weil man weiß
eigentlich gar nicht was einem
vermittelt wert und was man hinterfragen
darf und dann sagt man mir so der körper
der weibliche körper ist tatsächlich die
quelle aller sünde und ist böse aber
großer widersprüche unmöglich zu
vereinbaren aber hier ist es erstmal der
weibliche körper ist auch sehr heilig
und kann für heilige zwecke eingesetzt
werden und zwar für den heiligsten zweck
überhaupt kinder zu gebären und jetzt
ist dein körper sozusagen beides ist der
quelle der sünde
er ist böse ist aber auch für den
heiligsten zweck zu nutzen und es wird
immer an diese dichotomie dargestellt
dass man sagt schau dein körper ist zwei
wochen im monat unrein weil du blut ist
und diese und diese blut macht den
körper unrein und du musst schauen dass
du erst mal sieben rheine
tag erzählen kannst bevor du dich ins
rituale rituelle bad begibst und danach
wieder rein bist und für diese zwei
reine wochen wirst du dein körper für
diesen zweck der fortpflanzung einsetzen
und zwar hast du in deinem körper
tatsächlich diesen flur am ende diese
dieses fluges gibt es einen so eine art
altar an diesem altar wird ein opfer
dargelegt so das wird halt so eine
beschrieben das ist das ist ja ein
märchen dass das kann man eigentlich gar
nicht begreifen was das bedeuten soll
aber was denkt man dann als mädchen in
diesem moment man denkt es schaffen es
irgendwie alle andere frauen es kommen
ja ständig in diese gemeinde kinder auf
die welt wenn dies schaffen wir das auch
schaffen es wird irgendwie hinhauen
und ich bin dann etwas nervös aber mit
mit vertrauen zurück zur hochzeit
gegangen und meinte es wird irgendwie
klappen
und sie haben dann aber natürlich auch
aufgrund dieser ganzen und radierungen
und aufgrund dieser ganzen belastungen
quasi auch psychisch dass man als frau
weiß man ist in gewisser weise schmutzig
und heilig gleichzeitig extrem viele
probleme gehabt im ersten ehe ja sie
beschreiben das unglaublich eindrücklich
in ihrem buch auch wie sie ein wagnis
muss entwickelt haben
man muss jetzt natürlich auf dieser
basis auch verstehen dass was für einer
gemeinde sie kommen sie sind eben in
einer ultraorthodoxen jüdischen gemeinde
aufgewachsen die man die sattmacher
kasse team nennt die in brooklyn new
york soweit ich weiß die größte anzahl
an mitglieder hat sie haben kürzlich
auch wieder von sich reden gemacht weil
sie die die regeln in der korona zeit
nicht einhalten wollten
können sie uns kurz die gesinnung dieser
gemeinde skizzieren und woher kommt die
ja so kurz wie möglich weil uns geht es
eigentlich nicht aber ich versuche die
gemeinde beschreibt sich selber als
rassistische gemeinde
die ist aber nicht unbedingt akkurat
diese beschreibung weil die politische
bewegung die er
18 jahrhundert in osteuropa ihren start
hatte war damals eine sehr radikale
mystische bewegung ein art rebellion
gegen die orthodoxie und am anfang hat
diese bewegung ihren mitgliedern sehr
viel freiheit angeboten
wir haben erst eine änderung gesehen als
er konkurrierende bewegungen in europa
gestartet sind zum beispiel die
aufklärung die jüdische aufklärung oder
zionismus
das heißt dass es plötzlich andere wege
gab die juden gehen konnten dass sie
sich integrieren konnten emanzipieren
konnten oder eben zionisten werden es
gab einfach so viele möglichkeiten sich
als jüdische definieren plötzlich dass
die klassische bewegung als reaktion
darauf weil sie diese konkurrierende
bewegungen als bedrohung sahen haben
sich dann fundamentalistischer
entwickelt und schon am anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts gab es ein
rabbiner in der stadt hat omari an der
grenze von ungarn und rumänien
der damals schon gesagt hat dass gott
eine ultimative strafe schon vorbereitet
weil die juden sich assimilieren und
weise zionisten werden weil warum es
gibt ja diese diese traditionelle glaube
im orthodoxen judentum das als die juden
zum zweiten mal ins exil vertrieben
worden sind nachdem der zweite tempel
zerstört wurde
haben sie einen pakt mit guard mit gott
geschlossen und zwar hat gott ihnen
gesagt dass er irgendwann einen dritten
ewigen tempel aufbauen würde aber dafür
musste man drei dinge stören und zwar
erste sure war man dürfte das land nicht
selbst zurückerobern
zweite war man musste sich der
autoritäten im exil bedingungslos
unterwerfen und der dritte war
man muss dass ich immer von den fremden
völkern im exil unterscheiden
und diese drei schwere werden sehr ernst
genommen wurden sie immer sehr ernst
gramm in der orthodoxie und die ganze
orthodoxie basiert ja darauf dass man
glaubt man ist dem exil
man arbeitet seine sünden ab man wartet
dass man den messias verdient dass die
erlösung kommt und dann
der dritte tempel für die ewigkeit da
und dies hat mahler juden glaubten schon
vor dem krieg das dass die assimilation
und die emanzipation und der zionismus
eigentlich so beweise dafür waren dass
die juden diese diesen pakt diese drei
schwere vergessen weil sie sie
unterwerfen sich nicht mehr
die unterscheiden sich von den anderen
völkern nicht mehr und die versuchen
selbst es lang zurückzunehmen
und als der holler kost passiert hat
erstmal rabbiner gesagt ich hab das ich
hab das doch vorher gesagt und als er
dann sich von einem zionist von von dem
rudolf kastner sich retten lassen hatte
weil er dann glaubte dass er sozusagen
der mann dafür war nach dem krieg denen
sozusagen hinterlassenen bröckeln des
volkes wieder aufzufinden war
der ist dann nach new york in 46 schon
und hat angefangen langsam die die
überlebende die die schritt für schritt
sozusagen nach amerika kamen um sich zu
sammeln und hat ihm gesagt diesen
menschen die so traumatisiert waren die
alles verloren haben hat ihm gesagt ich
weiß warum es passiert ist ich habe es
vorher gesagt ich kann euch jetzt einen
lebensweg ein rezept für ein lebensweg
geben der sozusagen eigentlich dafür da
ist eine wiederholung so eine strafe zu
vermeiden aber natürlich auch um diesen
überlebens schuld irgendwie entgegen zu
setzen oder zu treten weil diese
überleben da ich rede jetzt auch ganz
spezifische über meine großeltern die
den holocaust überlebt haben und alles
verloren hatten
die haben wirklich die haben sich
schuldig gefühlt die haben nicht das
gefühl gehabt dass die das leben
verdient haben
die haben sich gerne entbehrungen
auferlegt dass das hat dann auch gepasst
und da sagte der rabbiner
wir mussten dieses leben die diesen
lebensweg jetzt gehen weil wir müssen
gott besänftigen gottes wütend auf uns
und nur in dem wir alle jüdische rituale
und traditionen extrem und neu
interpretieren interpretieren können wir
ihn besänftigen können wir schauen dass
er
wie seinen zorn im griff hat und genau
aus dieser erfahrung eben auch aus
dieser dramatischen erfahrung der show
erklärt sich daneben auch diese enge und
die abgrenzung auch oder die dagmar
jetzt leben und aus diesen schüren diese
gesagt haben genau wobei dieser
abgrenzung hat sich über den jahren auch
extreme entwickelt weil die center also
die gemeinde würde ich sagen ist erst in
den 50er jahren in amerika so eine
richtige gemeinde geworden somit eine
richtige identität und so unsichtbare
grenzen um sich herum
aber dann kam halt in der modernen
gesellschaft um sie herum die zivile
rechte bewegung feminismus dann paar
jahrzehnte später die technologie und
diese diese änderungen in der außenwelt
haben sie als als große bedrohung
wahrgenommen und haben sich sozusagen
bei jeder schritt in die richtung
progressivität sozusagen sich noch
radikaler ausgelegt und sich noch weiter
abgeschottet das heißt die abschied die
abschottung war auch ein prozess der
dann immer extremer wurde
und auch wenn ich zum beispiel an meine
kindheit zurückdenken hat sich die
gemeinde auch seitdem natürlich extrem
entwickelt und sich versucht noch mehr
abzuschotten
jetzt gibt es ja viele leute die von den
sattmacher sie dem als eine sekte
sprechen wir haben mit der
religionswissenschaftlerin dorothea
denkens darüber gesprochen wie sinnvoll
dass das ist ich denke dass der sekten
uns begriff uns da nur bedingt weiter
hilft weil wir haben bei den begriff
sekte so viele negative assoziationen
also denken an so viel negative aspekte
die entweder gar nicht oder vielleicht
nur zum teil auf diese gemeinschaft zu
treffen
also es gibt vielleicht eher eine ist es
eher eine gemeinschafts form die wir
vielleicht als eine umfassende oder
vereinnahmende ja in gewisser weise
sogar ganzheitliche gemeinschaft
bezeichnen könnten
das ist es eine gemeinschaft die
wirklich das ganze leben ihrer
mitglieder prägt von der geburt bis zum
tod wenn sie in der gemeinschaft sind
dann ist ihre ehe davon
sie werden ihre kinder entsprechend
erziehen ihre freizeit ihre kleidung ihr
umgang mit ihrem eigenen körper all das
es mit bestimmt von den regeln und
vorstellungen und werten und erzählungen
der gemeinschaft wie stehen diesmal
kassierten im gros der extrem diversen
religiösen strömungen innerhalb des
judentums dar
ich glaube das ist eine ganz ganz
wichtige frage also dass es eine
gemeinschafts form und es ist eine
mögliche jüdische lebensform aber
wirklich nur eine unter einer
unglaublich großen vielfalt innerhalb
des judentums
also es gibt liberale gemeinden die
homosexuelle jüdinnen oder transgender
juden willkommen heißen was jetzt bei
den fahrern eher schwierig wäre oder
schwierig ist und es gibt orthodoxe also
sich wirklich auch selber als orthodoxe
gemeinden verstehende jüdische gemeinden
die einerseits bestimmte richtlinien des
religiösen lebens bewahren wollen zum
beispiel die speisegesetze und
gleichzeitig aber auch säkulare bildung
sehr sehr hoch einschätzen das ist etwas
was bei den zockern zum beispiel eine
geringe rolle spielt eher geringe rolle
insofern ist das wichtig im kopf zu
behalten es ist eine form jüdischen
lebens aber es ist nicht das judentum
das judentum ist viel vielfältiger und
weiter als das was wir dort kennenlernen
autoritäre strukturen
parallelgesellschaften vereinnahmen die
prozesse unlautere methoden wo soll denn
religiöse toleranz ändern
schwierige frage also religiöse toleranz
religionsfreiheit das sind ja ganz
wichtige werte auf die wir hier auch
stolz sind in unserer gesellschaft
gleichzeitig denke ich also die
schweizer gesellschaft der schweizer
staat hat sich verpflichtet versteht
sich im rahmen der menschenrechte und
das ist natürlich ein weiter begriff das
ist eine frage auch die perspektive und
manchmal fällt das eigene da leichter zu
verstehen und auch im rahmen der männer
schon rechte zu akzeptieren als das was
an fremd ist und gleichzeitig denke ich
ein staat ist er verantwortlich für
seine bürgerinnen und bürger und ganz
besonders für diejenigen die nicht
selbst entscheiden können für sich also
für kinder und jugendliche vor allem
auch und da hat ein staat auch eine eine
fürsorgepflicht und eine verantwortung
auch grenzen zu ziehen
und ich denke da sollte nicht alles im
namen von religion erlaubt sein
also nicht nur weil es eine religiöse
motivation oder begründung gibt muss ein
staat das auch tolerieren verstellt man
sie haben während des ein spiel das auch
genügt hätten sie sich denn gewünscht
dass der amerikanische staat weniger
tolerant gewesen wäre
es geht eigentlich gar nicht so sehr um
toleranz in amerika weil da ist das
politische system so anders da steht ja
natürlich religionsfreiheit über alles
das ist ja ein altes prinzip in amerika
und das politisch das politische system
ist so strukturiert dass das auf
kommunaler ebene sehr gut funktioniert
dass diese gemeinde zum beispiel immer
als einstimmiger blog sozusagen wählt
und das heißt dass kein politiker ins
amt kommen kann ohne diese gemeinde und
das bedeutet dass sie mit dieser
gemeinde verhandeln müssen und so zu
sagen dass die zivilrecht am ende halt
bei dieser gemeinde gar nicht fällig
sind also diese nicht relevant
die gemeinde ist immer politisch gesehen
eine ausnahme und muss sich nicht an den
gesetzen halten weil die politiker nur
ins amt kommen wenn sie hinweg schauen
und deshalb wert ja immer wieder hinweg
geschaut und deshalb gibt es immer noch
bis heute obwohl es ein zivilrecht ist
für jede amerikanischer bürger keine
weltliche ausbildung
obwohl die schulen öffentlich finanziert
werden
ja und das ist einfach nur ein beispiel
und das kann ja nur in amerika passieren
weil das system so funktioniert es ist
der gleiche beispiel mit den richtern
zum beispiel
es ist ganz anders als in europa die
richter
denn die sind schon von den hiesigen
gemeinden wo sie fungieren abhängig das
heißt oft ist es schon so dass wenn man
als orthodoxe frau vor gericht geht um
sich scheiden zu lassen um sorgerecht
für seine kinder zu kämpfen natürlich
dass man vor einem richter steht genau
dass der richter dann entweder selber
orthodox ist oder von der orthodoxen
gemeinde so abhängig ist dass der
niemals unvoreingenommen entscheiden
kann und werde und deshalb musste ich ja
auch selber wegziehen damit ich
überhaupt eine chance hatte vor einem
fairen richter zu stehen
genau darüber reden wir später noch weil
das hat er auch andere konsequenzen
finanziell noch lassen sie uns noch kurz
auf die neue serie die wir zu beginn
gesehen haben eingehen ihre
lebensgeschichte fließt der eben ein es
ist nicht alles nur darauf gebaut aber
das ist quasi die ausgangslage eben
schirachs die israelische schauspielerin
spielt es die die quasi sie ist haben
sie sich in ihr und in ihrem schauspiel
wiedererkannt
es gab jedenfalls momente die mir
vertraut vorkommen so gewisse besondere
momente es gab auch momente wo ich
gedacht habe wenn nur ich so gewesen
wäre welche da also aber da in dieser
figur ja es gibt einen moment im
schlafzimmer wo sie endlich mal ihrem
ehemann alles dann sagt was im kopf was
ihr in ihrem kopf vorkommt und ich hatte
keinen moment genau wie dieser ich hatte
vielleicht so ganz kleine momente hier
und da wo ich ein bisschen dampf
abgelassen habe aber ich habe keinen
moment wie wi fi sd
wie sie dann als vulkan einfach über
läuft so also das hatte ich nicht und da
war ich so vielleicht sogar kurzzeitig
aber wir haben auch sti als figur
konzipiert die ein bisschen an eine
fantasie sein sollte ein
sie sollte zumindest eine figur sein
worin sich viele extras idem oder leute
die vielleicht extra sie dem sein wollen
sich spiegeln können
das wollten wir und deshalb ist sie
nicht nur sozusagen auf mich angelehnt
sondern wir haben auch mit anderen
aussteigern gesprochen und versucht eine
figur zu schaffen die die erfahrungen
mehrere aussteige reflektiert was ich
mich schon stark gefragt habe ich meine
sie haben jetzt in zwei büchern ihre
geschichte schon verarbeitet trotzdem
das ist sie schreiben dort selbst und
plötzlich bekommen sie ihre eigene
geschichte jedenfalls zum teil wieder
vorgespielt war das nicht dann
unglaublich auch schmerzhafter prozess
ich versuche vielleicht präzisere worte
zu finden
jedenfalls ist es so dass die zwei
frauen die diese serie kreiert haben die
sind gute freunde von mir
wir haben jahrelang darüber geredet
bevor es überhaupt dazu kam das ist
offiziell wurde am anfang war es nur ein
witz dann würde es ernster aber wir
haben wirklich in dieser serie in allen
hinsichten rauf und runter diskutiert
das heißt an dem punkt als wir anfingen
zu casten und zu filmen
da gab es keine überraschungen ich
wusste schon alles im voraus ich war
sehr gut vorbereitet ich war mit diesen
frauen emotional sehr eng
ich hab da das vollste vertrauen gehabt
sehr viel klarheit dann kamen die folgen
zu mir im herbst 2009 10
und ich war sehr gut vorbereitet und es
gab tatsächlich keine überraschungen
aber klar in dem moment gerade zb bei
der dritten folge wo es diese sehr harte
szenen gibt ich kann jedenfalls ehrlich
berichten dass sich dann teilweise so am
rand eines sitzes war und habe den atem
dann die ganze zeit eingehalten weil ich
angst hatte ich habe angst dass diese
schauspielerin schirachs es vielleicht
doch nicht hinkriegt diese geschichte
von dieser figur erzählen zu lassen ohne
dabei die würde und die integrität diese
figur verletzt zusehen weil ich
natürlich mir die gleiche sorgen gemacht
habe als ich das buch schrieb wie
schreibt man über so eine geschichte
ohne peinlich zu sein billig zu sein
sexy zu sein
es ist einfach wahnsinnig schwierig man
hat das gefühl es gibt keinen richtigen
weg man ist egal was man tut als mensch
dann in seiner würde verletzt und ich
habe das gefühl gehabt als sie schrieb
ich würde auf einen draht gehen so und
ich glaube die schauspielerin schierer
hass hat das gleiche gefühl gehabt als
sie als sie diese rolle gespielt hat und
ich glaube es hat ihr wahnsinnig viel
energie gekostet
die hat sich damit mit herz und seele
reingeschmissen hat diese rolle geatmet
und geschlafen und gegessen und hat
nichts anderes gemacht als ich in diese
rolle hinein zu fühlen und ich glaube
sie hat diese angst auch gespürt und
gerade vielleicht deshalb weil sie diese
angst so tief in ihrem körper gespürt
hat hat sie es hat sie es hingekriegt
diesen draht zu gehen ohne runter zu
stürzen
trotzdem frage ich mich und ich erlaube
mir das noch mal zu fragen kam alter
schmerz auf sie zurück als sie das
gesehen haben sie haben jetzt gesagt sie
haben das eben auch begleitet das
endprodukt dann ist er trotzdem noch mal
was anderes jetzt haben sich auch die
die quasi die zweite die zweiten teilen
als sie konkret in berlin ist
angesprochen
ja ja klar also auf jeden fall
obwohl ich dachte gut vorbereitet zu
sein gab es momente als sich die folgen
geschaut habe ich gemerkt habe ich habe
doch nicht alles so gut verarbeitet wie
ich vielleicht gedacht hatte und
vielleicht gibt es noch ein war ein
langer weg vor mir und ich mache jetzt
seit eh und je eine therapie und ich bin
ich habe nämlich dass ich im november
glaube ich zu meiner therapeutin
gegangen bin und und meinte so wir
mussten eigentlich alles auspacken was
wir schon weggepackt haben weil es ist
doch nicht so alles so ordentlich wie
müssen vielleicht hätte sein sollen
aber es war auch ein geschenk es ist
auch ein geschenk solche momente im
leben
zu haben über sich zu erfahren ich habe
da keine angst die wahrheit über mich zu
erfahren ich habe keine angst vorm eine
eigene emotionale schwächen oder meine
verletzlichkeit und ich bin ich alle
mich auch gar nicht im leben anzukommen
ich glaube nicht dass es im leben
tatsächlich darum geht angekommen zu
sein sondern danach zu streben und
vielleicht hat die serie sogar da
geholfen
es gab eine rezension in der welt von
alan posener der gesagt hat aus der
serie oder aus einer serie die den
tragischen konflikt zwischen tradition
und emanzipation thematisieren müsste
wird ein feelgood movie für berliner
hipster und solche die es gerne wären
gemacht können sie das irgendwie
nachvollziehen auch nachdem sie jetzt
gesagt haben es sei ein drahtseilakt und
um sie habe diese person geatmet usw
diese figur also die die bedeutung
seiner worte kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen aber es ist schon klar
dass so männer wie allen posner und
michael wolf
diese position vertreten würden weil sie
diese positionen ja immer vertreten und
als als als frau mit so eine geschichte
wie meine ist man ja immer auf solche
stimmen vorbereitet man ist daran
gewöhnt und ich wenn jemand mir dann
vorher hätte fragen wollen wie denkst du
wird allen posen reagieren hätte ich das
genau so dargestellt dass er so
reagieren wurde
aber es gebe mittlerweile ja sowohl den
deutschsprachigen raum als im
englischsprachigen sehr sehr gute
antworten auf diesen texten
es gab zum beispiel ein text in der
wiener zeitung
kurzgefasst nicht jede unliebsame
darstellung des antisemitisch ja sehr
guter punkt
andererseits gab es ein sehr
interessanter text von einem akademiker
in amerika
der eigentlich für so ein thema experte
ist anders als wolffsohn und poster
einen sehr großartigen text worin
erklärt wird was wir eigentlich
vorhatten dass berlin und williamsburg
wie sie in der serie dargestellt werden
sind nicht berlin in williamsburg als
dokumentarisches objekt sondern als
archetypen die in dem kopf der
protagonisten gegeneinander prallen da
sind fantasieren sozusagen die in ihre
erfahrungen in ihren perspektiven sich
entfalten und zwar als als sozusagen
gegenseitiger typen und wer das nicht
versteht will das nicht verstehen
gehen wir weiter gehen wir auch zu ihrem
zweiten buch im überbieten
da schreiben sie eigentlich alles was
danach geschehen ist nach dieser flucht
sie haben dieses buch ihrer oma gewidmet
denken sich sie hat das buch in die
finger bekommen nein also sie war nicht
mehr am leben als das buch
veröffentlicht wurde
aber ich finde mich meine großmutter bis
heute noch sehr nah sehr nahe geister
sie beeinflusst mich sehr
ich habe alle meine stärkste
charaktereigenschaften von ihr gelernt
alle meine ressourcen von diese
beziehung mit ihr und vielleicht
vielleicht macht eine schriftstellerin
sowas auch für sich selbst vielleicht
ist die widmung dann für mich was
persönliches ich ich denke dass meine
leber ich denke dass mein leben eine
widmung meine großmutter ist
das ist sehr berühren was sie sagen man
merkt auch dass sie sehr traurig sind
darüber sie hatten ja nach ihrem
austritt keinen kontakt mehr zu ihr ja
richtig
was ich beeindruckend und schrecklich
zugleich finde auch in der lektüre
dieses buches ist sie hatten einen
ersten befreiungsschlag
und er war irgendwie gar kein richtiger
befreiungsschlag sondern zuerst mal ein
rückschlag sie haben
sie mussten nach manhattan ziehen
aufgrund dieser ganzen sorgerechts
geschichte ist eine komplexe geschichte
die soll sich der zuschauer besser
selber nachlesen aber sie haben dort
gelebt hat eine teure wohnung hatten
irgendwie kein geld viel zeit wie muss
man sich das vorstellen dass sie
trotzdem die ganze zeit weiter gemacht
haben
wie war das möglich ich hatte ein kind
ich musste für das kind jeden tag
aufstehen frühstück machen das kind in
die kita bringen das kind abholen
abendessen kochen baden also es gab ein
ein zeitplan es gab eine routine es gab
ein kind das von mir abhängig war und
sehr viel von mir erwartet hatte und
dass das war zugleich ein last aber auch
ein großes geschenk weil es mich als hat
mir orientierung gegeben und es ist die
erklärung warum ich es geschafft habe
und es ist auch die erklärung warum
frauen die ihre kinder verlieren sich
dann umbringen weil sie selber kein
lebenssinn mehr finden
ja sie sprechen etwas wichtiges an also
ganz viele aussteiger erlebt neben sich
auch das leben sie schreiben sie können
selber einige die das getan haben dass
er das ist eines der schicksale die
leute haben wenn sie aus dieser
gemeinschaft aussteigen weil das so
stark das ganze leben
durchzogen ist von der gemeinschaft und
von allen religiösen ritualen oder wie
wie es gilt es das zu verstehen
es ist tatsächlich sehr komplex da
hängen sehr viele faktoren zusammen
ein großer faktor ist dass sehr viele
aussteiger versuchen irgendwie noch
halbwegs kontakt mit gewissen
familienmitgliedern zum zu behalten und
das bedeutet dass sie einen die lassen
sozusagen einen kanal offen also kanäle
offen dass die gemeinde sie erreichen
kann
und das bedeutet dass sie sich
verletzlich machen die gemeinde kann sie
dann manipulieren schikanieren zum zuge
zieht auch anstacheln weil es liegt ja
in deren interesse dass dass diese
menschen sich umbringen weil da können
sie immer sozusagen den zweiflern in der
gemeinde dann sagen schau das ist das
was passiert wenn man weggeht das wird
mit dir passieren wenn du weg ist es
sozusagen die sind darin investiert dass
wir sozusagen auf schrecklichste art
scheitern
und dann gibt es ein anderer faktor dass
man halt in der außenwelt nicht ankommt
vor allem weil man diesen kontakt
aufrecht erhält bleibt man so in so
einer art zwischenwelt man gehört nicht
dahin woher man kommt man kann
eigentlich nie wirklich zurück weil auch
wenn man zurückgehen würde wäre es nicht
wäre es nie so zu sagen das gleiche wie
vorher wie die figur mancher auch in der
serie sagt aber gleichzeitig gibt es
diese große schwierigkeit dass man nicht
dafür ausgerüstet wurde in der außenwelt
überhaupt fuß zu fassen
man kann sich oft selber kein
lebensunterhalt sichern man kann schwer
freunde finden man kann sozusagen die
ausbildung muss man von vorne anfangen
an und man weiß eigentlich gar nicht wo
anzufangen und man hat riesige angst
dass man diese außenwelt nie wirklich
verstehen wird und dass man einem nicht
verstehen wert und man steht sozusagen
in zwischen diesen zwei welten und der
weg in die außenwelt ist lange und
scheint unmöglich
da kommt die gemeinde und sagt es ist
unmöglich
das hat niemand geschafft das willst du
auch nicht schaffen und hier zurück
wirst du das auch nicht hinkriegen also
bringt dich einfach um und dann kommen
halt zusätzliche schwierigkeiten
vielleicht hat man missbrauch erfahren
als kind vielleicht ist einem die kinder
weggenommen worden vielleicht hat man
depressionen oder ist es gibt so viele
zusätzliche faktoren und und für die
meisten ist es einfach absolut unmöglich
und die die ich kenne die es geschafft
haben da gibt es immer gemeinsame fäden
absolute kontaktabbruch physische
distanz zwischen einem und die
vergangenheit entweder keine kinder
gehabt zu haben oder kind behalten zu
können und man musste natürlich eine
chance bekommen vielleicht ich denke an
einem guten freund von mir da auch in
berlin wohnt der das geschafft hat in
die ecole de posa in paris da
reinzukommen und das zu studieren und
diese umgebung hat dem dann so vieles
ermöglicht und so viele verbindungen
gegeben bei mir war das science college
da hat man mir ohne hochschulabschluss
genommen einfach weil ich drei aufsätze
schrieb und diese diese schulung hat mir
so viel mehr als schulung gegeben das
hat mir eine welt erschlossen es hat mir
für bindungen geschafft ist es hat mir
eigentlich in allen hinsichten geholfen
es ist der grund warum ich ein buch
schreiben dürfte warum ich eine anwältin
bekommen habe das heißt man braucht
schon die chance mit braucht schon dass
die außenwelt sich einem öffnet und das
passiert selten und ich muss noch eine
sache dazu sagen dass das größte problem
für aussteige wie ich ist dass die das
der höchste maß an diskriminierung und
vorurteile erfahren wir in der jüdischen
welt und gerade so von von solchen
menschen wie alan posener und michael
wolf die meine geschichte so kritisch
angehen und es so schlimm finden das so
leute wie ich eine stimme haben
die sind ja auch nicht die dann dastehen
mit offenen armen wenn so menschen wie
ich dann aussteigen und sagen kommt mal
zu uns wir nehmen euch auf wir helfen
euch da kriegen wir keine hilfe da
kriegen wir nur vorurteile wie es in der
serie auch gezeigt wird zwischen er
l&s dhl ist eine säkulare israelis die
aber sich mit den orthodoxen auskennen
und sagt was ist die sd die ist ein baby
maschine
was wird aus ihren nichts so sie sagt du
wirst es nie nachholen können du wirst
nie wie uns und genau das ist es was uns
gesagt wert wenn wir aussteigen von
anderen juden und ist genau der grund
warum wir tatsächlich den weiten ausweg
suchen mussten um dahin zu gehen wo die
leute uns nicht genug kennen um
sozusagen diese vorurteile gegen uns zu
haben und uns die chancen zu verwehren
und das schätzen sie ja auch an berlin
deswegen sind es ja auch jetzt in berlin
geblieben weil das auch so
multikulturell ist wie ich sie
verstanden habe ich möchte noch ganz
kurz wir sind fast am ende der sendung
darauf eingehen sie haben gesagt man
muss mit allem brechen heißt es auch
weil die religiöse tradition der
horizont war vor dem sie ihr leben bis
dahin eigentlich gelebt haben dass man
auch mit der religion brechen muss
konkret gefragt gibt es für sie noch an
bezug dazu beten sie noch nein ich würde
nicht sagen dass ich bete und ich würde
sagen dass wenn man in so eine art von
gemeinde aufwächst egal welche religion
wird das danach sehr sehr schwierig
überhaupt einen bezug zur religion zu
finden der irgendwas mit gruppenbildung
oder gemeinde zu tun hatte man kann das
nur dann als individuum aussuchen und
sich dabei noch sicher fühlen
das heißt wenn ich eines wenn ich eine
spiritualität in meinem leben noch habe
dann ist es auf jeden fall eine sehr
individuelle und solange es individuell
bleibt ist die spiritualität da aber
wenn ich das gefühl habe eine gemeinde
will das sozusagen für eine vereinnahmen
dann breche ich sozusagen damit weil ich
kann nur einen individuellen bezug haben
das so dass ich mich nicht dadurch
bedroht fühle oder eingeengt fühlen und
das ist dann halt ein sonderfall
was bei vielen aussteigern
so passiert wenn ich jetzt weniger
extrem ausgewachsen wäre dann vielleicht
wäre ich auch nicht so extrem drauf
heutzutage aber es ist nachvollziehbar
dass das alle art von gruppendenken mich
sehr erschreckt
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich für dieses
offene gespräch frau feldmann ganz
herzlichen dank danke dass ich gast sein
dürfte
[Musik]